I ask you a question Pat where on earth
is Mike Pence I've been wondering for
weeks and I've been thinking actually of
doing a story on this is Mike Pence
staying out of the spotlight because he
doesn't want to be associated with a
disaster that is the Trump
administration is Trump because of his
narcissism keeping pence away from the
public eye there's a bunch of different
possibilities here and then over the
weekend we get a report about Mike Pence
which claims that Donald Trump has
started to ask around about whether
Pence is actually loyal to him and we
know that that's not good we know that
not long after Trump asked FBI director
James Comey are you loyal can I count on
your loyalty
he ended up firing James Comey we know
that in the White House it's known that
when Trump starts asking around about
the loyalty of associates it is often a
precursor to them getting fired and as a
further sort of precursor to this there
was this very strange moment when Donald
Trump gave remember that off-the-wall
press conference that Trump gave right
after the midterms where he was acting
like he had won the Super Bowl and is
going to Disney World even though
Republicans had just gotten crushed the
topic of okay well it is Mike Pence your
running mate for 2020 because you've
filed for re-election but you haven't
actually said is Mike Pence running with
you and this happened take a look mister
mr. president one more question oh my
I'm so sorry it's rare opportunity a lot
of people are gonna be rushing to Iowa
rushing to New Hampshire you know that
the Democrats are already looking ahead
to 2020 do you want to lock down your
ticket right now sir will the vice
president be your running mate in 2020
well I haven't asked him but I hope so
where are you Mike will you be my
running mate
stand up Mike please raise your right
hand now I'm all good
will you thank you okay good yeah the
answers yes sir thank you sir
that was unexpected but I feel very fine
so what was that at the end from saying
that was unexpected but I feel fine it
could be a joke except for the fact that
Trump has never indicated that he even
has the smallest sense of humor
whatsoever and it turns out based on
really good reporting from the New York
Times that Trump may be questioning
Pence's loyalty that he's been asking
around about is pence actually loyal to
him he's been asking advisers he's been
asking aides and some aides have heard
Trump ask this so many times that they
are now alarmed now no one is saying
Trump is talking about kicking pence off
the 20/20 ticket nobody's saying that at
this point but what they are saying is
that they are able to do pattern
recognition as homo sapiens and that
they've identified that when Trump
starts asking about loyalty that means
in many cases that he's about to get rid
of somebody and Bob Woodward actually
wrote about this in his book which is
Trump asking about loyalty is a
precursor to firing people for the most
part his staff says yes Mike Pence is
loyal but there is one aspect of this
that they say maybe there are better
options than pence I guess is the way to
say it and the the underlying logic
behind it Pat is pence was part of the
appeal to evangelical Christian voters
that that's a group that Trump didn't
initially do so well with but ultimately
got enough evangelical support to win
and that the choice of pence was
important for that the consensus at this
point is that Trump basically has all
the evangelical support that he's going
to get and that there's an opportunity
maybe to replace pence with somebody
that would help him with female voters
so that's not Pat an argument about
pence being disloyal to Trump or Trump
being mad or anything like that it pens
but it is the sort of strategic reality
that maybe there are better options than
pens
well talking strategy here I think Trump
would have to choose someone who is just
as crazy on the social issues as Pence
is because
pence right now is kind of serving as
Trump's buffer like no one wants to
impeach Trump because they worry that
pence is going to be worse in some
aspects and that's why I think he's
keeping him around and I think he will
keep him around for the the ticket in
2020 but yeah I don't know who the
replacement would be but he would have
to be just as stringent on issues like
refusing gay rights and you know wanting
to ban abortion and all that stuff and
yet maybe appeal more to women which can
be tough if you have that position on
abortion but maybe it does exist
there's also another explanation for why
Trump hasn't formally announced Pence is
his running mate in 2020 which is that
Trump might be truly genuinely so
panicked about the Russia investigation
and like the 50 other scandals that he's
just not thinking about 2020 although
knowing Trump he's probably thinking
about it somewhat now as far as the
actual question is mike pence loyal I
have no idea pence has every reason not
to be loyal to Trump we still haven't
even been able to rule out that pence
wrote that scathing anonymous New York
Times op-ed one other possibility in
terms of why Trump is asking asking
about loyalty might not mean he's
looking to fire pence
maybe loyalty by pence is code for pence
would pardon Trump if Trump was
ultimately removed and charged and pence
ended up being president of the United
States and if that is true I mean that's
just stunning the the idea that the
President of the United States would be
thinking about that let me hear from you
I mean what do you think is the point of
trumps question is Mike Pence actually
loyal to me one of today's sponsors is
privacy calm slash Pakman this is a free
service that I've actually been using
myself for a while now and I love it you
just take a few seconds to link your
debit card or bank account to privacy
coms mobile app or browser extension for
Firefox and Chrome and what that does is
allow you to instantly create virtual
credit cards that are linked to your
bank account so that you're not actually
putting your
debit card number on the Internet and
you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5.00 towards your first purchase
when you sign up using that link below